estoy un final para la campaña electoral
en eeuu ambos candidatos se apuran las
últimas 48 horas antes del día de las
elecciones para cautivar el voto de los
indecisos las encuestas nacionales
muestran a bailén con una ventaja de
siete u ocho puntos porcentuales sobre
champ pero jefe del ejecutivo no lo da
todo por perdido especialmente porque en
algunos sitios está muy empatado con su
contrincante por eso este domingo ha
programado una gira por cinco estados en
michigan iowa la realidad del norte
georgia y florida son esos estados los
que pueden acabar decidiendo quién
ocupará la casa blanca durante los
próximos cuatro años por lo que tanto
demócratas como republicanos han
intensificado sus esfuerzos en estas
zonas de estados unidos también
pensilvania es un estado que está en la
mira de la campaña ayer sábado el actual
mandatario visitó varias ciudades desde
ahí defendiendo su gestión ante la
crisis de el coronavirus prometiendo
miles de puestos de trabajo y aseguró
que él ha logrado la mejor situación
financiera de toda la historia del país
norteamericano por su parte joe biden ha
escogido filadelfia
bien en pensilvania para centrar el
meeting de este domingo con un evento
para animar a la participación el rival
de donald trump espera que en estas
elecciones se superen los récords de
votantes algunos apuntan a que más de
150 millones de estadounidenses podrían
acudir a las urnas hasta ahora ya han
votado más de 92 millones de personas en
todo el país una cifra que está muy por
encima de la mitad del refuerzo total de
votos de 2016 que votaron en total 138
millones de ciudadanos según datos desde
el proyecto de elecciones de eeuu